please Thank You a big day today at the
White House all of American society is
engaged and mobilized in the war against
the invisible enemy well we must remain
vigilant it is clear that our aggressive
strategy is working and very strongly
working on my debt new cases are
declining throughout the New York
metropolitan area cases in the Detroit
and Denver metro areas are flat
Washington d.c Baltimore Philadelphia
and st. Louis are showing great signs of
progress and new cases in Houston and
New Orleans are declining the battle
continues but the data suggests that
nationwide we have passed the peak on
new cases hopefully that will continue
and we will continue to make great
progress
these encouraging developments have put
us in a very strong position to finalize
guidelines for States on reopening the
country which we'll be announcing we're
going to be talking about that tomorrow
we'll be having a news conference
tomorrow sometime during the afternoon
we're going to be announcing guidelines
and we'll be talking about various
states and it's very exciting it's been
a horrible time to see such death and
destruction especially when you come out
of what was the greatest economy in the
history of the world the greatest we've
there's never been an economy like what
we had produced but we'll produce it
again and I think we'll produce it again
very fast the medical and healthcare
advances we've made are critical to our
continued progress we've rapidly
developed the most expansive an accurate
testing system anywhere in the world and
have completed more than 3.3 million
tests to date we have authorized 48
separate coronavirus tests and the FDA
is working with 300 companies and labs
to widen our capacity still further
today Abbott Labs announced that it has
developed an antibody test that will
determine if someone has been previously
infected with the corona virus and
potentially developed immunity it's a
great test the company says these tests
could be available to screen up to 20
million people in a matter of weeks my
administration is also distributing vast
amounts of medical supplies to states
across the country through project air
bridge which has been an amazing success
we have completed 44 flights and these
are flights of very very large airplanes
massive cargo planes 44 flights of
critical supplies as of today and an
additional 56 flights scheduled in the
near future we have some very brilliant
people working on this it's logistically
incredible what they've done and we've
also been working on this with the
military and these people have been the
genius of all of them together has been
incredible to watch in total through all
channels the federal government has
developed and delivered 39 point four
million n95 masks 431 million gloves 57
million surgical masks and ten point two
million gowns we ordered 500 million
masks and they'll be coming shortly and
we've distributed 100 million masks
following our use of the defense
production act GM announced that its
first ventilator has come off the
assembly line in Kokomo Indiana great
place they did it in 11 days from start
to finish a remarkable testament to the
ingenuity of the American worker GM will
ship over 600 ventilators this month
alone with thousands more to come and we
have other companies doing something
similar and I think they said that
there's a brief clip that we have of
General Motors sent to us by General
Motors and I think they might be wanting
to play that for your benefit please
[Music]
[Applause]
and there you get a little bit nervous
when you saw there was a clip about
ready to be played but that was sent to
us by General Motors and we thought it
would be a good one to play it's amazing
it says you know what they've done in a
very very short period of time they're
now making thousands of ventilators and
they're coming out of the factory very
rapidly at a clip that nobody can even
believe but we have others also doing it
and these are very high-grade
ventilators so we're helping a lot of
people and at this moment nobody needs
him we have to remember during the surge
nobody's needed in four weeks now but
we'll have them for stockpiles and very
importantly we're going to have them for
other countries because nobody is able
to do things like we can do and we're
going to be able to help other countries
that are having tremendous problems to
put it mildly my administration is using
every available Authority to accelerate
the development study and delivery of
therapies so important therapies
treatments and ultimately what we want
to come up with is a safe vaccine but
frankly the therapies to me are the most
important because it takes care of
people right now the vaccines have to be
tested so it takes a longer period of
time but we have some great potential
therapies already and we'll see how
they're working we'll be able to report
on that I think over the next week or
two tremendous progress has been made at
least 35 clinical trials
of promising therapies are now underway
so 35 different genius companies if you
look at AIDS if you look at a bola if
you look at so many things they've come
up with the answers to so many things
you wouldn't have believed it and we're
very honored to be working with them
they include antivirals and also in the
something which is incredible keeps the
virus from multiplying a mechanism that
keeps the virus from multiplying immune
therapies that prevent the immune system
from overreaching to the virus and
convalescent plasma treatments that use
antibodies from the blood of recovered
patients that we have a lot of patients
who recover and they're so
happy to have recovered that the first
thing they do is say we want to give our
blood and they do that it's incredible
we have thousands of people that are
doing that they recover they feel they
have an obligation because they've
gotten such great care and a lot of them
didn't think they were going to make it
as the entire US government works to
combat the global pandemic it is
absolutely essential that the key
positions at relevant federal agencies
are fully staffed and we're not allowing
that to take place through our Congress
they're just not they're just not giving
it to us we have many many positions
that are unstaffed because we can't get
the approvals the Democrats are holding
us up we cannot get approval we've
gotten judges because we go through the
process I guess we're up to 448 federal
judges and that we've gotten because we
focus on it we take the maximum time
because no matter who the judges they
take vast numbers of days and hours till
provent leaves no time left for others
very unfair system if a judge is going
to be approved in one hour in one
session it doesn't matter they'll take
the maximum number of hours and days
you're talking about days to get one
judge approved then we're close to 250
judges but because of the way they're
doing it there's no time for anybody
else and many of these people have been
waiting for two and a half years we have
a couple that have been waiting for
longer than that they're currently 129
nominees stuck in the Senate because of
partisan obstruction many are nominated
for vacancies that must be filled to
assist with the coronavirus crisis and
the resulting economic challenges and
I've read over the couple of years well
I didn't fill positions I don't fill
positions in some cases we don't need
the position and I'm all for that but in
many cases you do but we can't get them
approved by the Democrats they won't
release the positions include the
Director of National Intelligence two
members of the Federal Reserve Board of
Governors the Assistant Secretary of
Treasury for financial
markets of the United the United States
and the Under Secretary of Agriculture
responsible for administering food
security programs and sonny perdue who's
going to be speaking today saying please
can I have this man can I have this
particular person approved as soon as
possible he's been telling me that for a
long time and the Democrats won't allow
it to happen again every single judge
every nominee we have goes through
maximum or at least they go through a
long process so it takes days and days
and there's no time left and it's just a
concerted effort to make life difficult
an example is Michael pack he's my
nominee for the CEO of the broadcasting
broadcasting Board of Governors and he's
been stuck in committee for two years
preventing us from managing the voice of
America very important and have you
heard what's coming out of the voice of
America it's disgusting
well things they say are disgusting
toward our country and Michael pack
would get any do a great job but he's
been waiting now for two years
can't get him approved the Senate has
left Washington until at least May 4th
the Constitution provides a mechanism
for the president to fill positions in
such circumstances the recess
appointment it's called the Senate's
practice of gaveling into so-called pro
forma sessions where no one is even
there has prevented me from using the
constitutional authority that we're
giving that we're given under the
recessed provisions the Senate should
either fulfill its duty and vote on my
nominees or it should formally adjourn
so that I can make recess appointments
we have a tremendous number of people
that have to come into government and
now more so than ever before because of
the virus and the problem we have to do
it and we have to do whatever we have to
do they've made it very very difficult
to run government I don't think any
administer
raishin is done anywhere near what we've
done in three and a half years but every
block every week they put up roadblocks
whether it's Russia Russia Russia well
whether it's impeachment hoax or
whatever it may be it's always
roadblocks and a waste of time if the
house will not agree to that adjournment
I will exercise my constitutional
authority to adjourn both chambers of
Congress the current practice of leaving
town while conducting phony pro forma
sessions is a dereliction of duty that
the American people cannot afford during
this crisis it is a scam what they do
it's a scam and everybody knows it and
it's been that way for a long time and
perhaps it's never done before it's
never been done before nobody's even
sure if it has but we're going to do it
we need these people here
we need people for this crisis and we
don't want to play any more political
games I've been waiting for two and a
half years three years to some of these
people and they're great people they
left law firms they left jobs they gave
up everything to do it and they've been
waiting for three years two and a half
years two years one year to get approved
it's ridiculous and everyone knows
they're going to be approved but there's
only so many hours in the day when you
go through judges and you go through
lengthy hearings on judges that they
know should be approved immediately and
they could do it in one session one and
they could do it in one hour
and instead it takes so many days in
order to advance the health and security
of our nation and all nations as we
announced yesterday the US government
has put a hold on funding to the WHL
World Health Organization pending a
review of the organization's coverup and
mismanagement of the corona virus
outbreak over the objections of the WHL
we took decisive action and early
life-saving action to suspend travel
from China they didn't want to do it
they were angry that we did
it it was early on they were angry that
we did it took him a long time to
realize what was going but I have a
feeling they knew exactly what was going
on tragically other nations put their
trust in the w-h-o and they didn't do
any form of ban and you see what
happened to Italy you see what happened
to Spain you see what happened to France
WH shows guidance had failed to control
their borders at a very crucial phase
quickly unleashing the contagion around
the world there was a horrible tragic
mistake or perhaps they knew I'm sure
they didn't know the gravity of it but
perhaps they knew because if they knew
the gravity that would be an even worse
offence to ease the economic pain of
millions of American families we've now
processed 300 billion dollars in loans
to more than 1 million small businesses
through the paycheck protection program
this action has saved millions of
American jobs it's been an incredible
success and they want to replenish it
now but again the Democrats don't want
to do that this is money that goes to
the workers of our country phase one was
three hundred and fifty billion dollars
and now phase two we want to do two
hundred and fifty billion this goes to
workers and it goes to small businesses
so we can save all the small businesses
around our nation Mike McFarland from
Nebraska recently said this historic
relief has been a godsend for his small
factory and the 136 Americans who work
there save those jobs another small
business owner Tim Miller from Oklahoma
called the program a total lifesaver
fors auto repair shops for employees
stories like these underscore why
Congress must replenish the paycheck
protection program immediately the
Republicans want to do it they want to
do it immediately they want to do it now
and the Democrats are stopping it a
short time ago CDC issued public health
guidelines for critical industry
in a few moments agricultural secretary
sonny perdue will elaborate on how these
guidelines apply to our nation's
dedicated workers in the food processing
profession because it's a profession
it's incredible what they do food
processing and they're keeping our
grocery stories full the shelves are not
bare like the shelves that I inherited
when we took over the stockpile the
medical stockpile where the shelves were
bare the cupboard was bare I say
tomorrow I'll also be leading a call
with elected officials who will consult
with my administration as we work to
restore our economy to full speed and we
really think with all of the stimulus
and all of the pent-up demand we're
going to have an economy that really
comes back quickly and would like to see
it more than match what we had before
what we had before was a miracle and we
think this is going to be even more than
a miracle we're going to do it because
we have the greatest people in the world
we'll also be speaking to America's
governors tomorrow and then we'll be
announcing exactly what's happening you
already know we'll be opening up states
some states much sooner than others and
we think some of the states can actually
open up before the deadline of May first
and I think that that will be a very
exciting time indeed governors are
looking for that chomping at the bit to
get going again not all states are the
same they're very different some are
having very little problems some have
done such a good job that they have very
little problem and they're ready to go
so vice president pence and I will be
speaking with the governors tomorrow
we'll be discussing procedures today I
spoke with the leaders of many of our
nation's most renowned companies and
organizations on how to achieve the full
resurgence of the American economy my
discussions included top leaders in
health and health care transportation
technology financial services food
beverages hospitality real estate retail
agriculture construction energy labor
man
factoring in sports industries we want
to get a country open again we want to
have our sports leagues open you'll want
to watch sports it's important we miss
sports we miss everything we want to get
back these experts and innovators
provided extremely productive feedback
on how to safely reboot our economy they
gave us a lot of great ideas we spoke to
a lot of very very smart people the
highest of the high tech the level of IQ
and some of those calls was about the
highest you've ever seen heard a phone
call that I can tell you but we have a
lot of great thought went into those
calls and a lot of questions came out
and also statements very strong
statements as to what they recommend it
was I think it was a great day we did a
lot of a lot of calling with a lot of
very prominent people but more
importantly very smart people and people
that love our country they talked about
the vital importance of our wide array
of relief measures to address the
present crisis and they provided
valuable insights on how to move forward
including on the role of protective gear
where we have tremendous amounts of
protective gear coming in robust testing
and the future use of therapies and
treatments they also underscored the
crucial importance of strong supply
chains and communications infrastructure
we're talking about infrastructure for
the middle of our country talking about
broadband and things that they frankly
don't have and haven't had for a long
time because a lot of politicians forgot
about them
can't forget about them they're really
the heart and soul can't forget about
them and we're talking about the
telemedical it's a new thing and it's
incredible what they've been able to do
this is an industry that's just growing
but it's take it's grown by leaps and
bounds over the last five weeks people
are learning so much without the ability
to see a doctor they're learning so much
and a lot of good things are happening
that's something that's really going
forward I think going to be very
important for our country as we've seen
throughout our proud history America's
never greater than when our people are
working in unison toward a common goal
that's what's happening right now we'll
go ahead we'll forge an even brighter
future today than we had and will be
along with other nations hopefully we're
working with other nations will be the
comeback kids all of us all of us it's
incredible what's going on I'm very
proud of the people of this country I'm
very proud of the people I spoke to
today these are truly great brilliant
people and we've gained tremendous
insight so tomorrow is going to be a
very big day we're going to be speaking
with the governors we'll have some
information on some openings and again
we'll have some openings that will be
will exceed our expectations and they'll
be safe they'll be strong but we want to
get our country back we want to get our
country back and we're going to do it
and we're going to do it soon with that
I'd like to ask dr. Burks to come up and
say a few words and then secretary sonny
perdue and then vice president pence
thank you very much thank you thank you
Thank You mr. president and thank you
for summarizing on the States and what
we're seeing so over the last five to
six days we've seen declines in cases
across the country and this has been
very in reassuring for us at the same
time we know that mortality and the
fatalities that we're facing across the
United States continue we know the
number of people who are still in the
hospitals in the ICUs and we want to
continue to recognize the health care
workers who are on the front lines and
really recognize how low the United
States case fatality rates are compared
to other countries and this is really
due not only to our technology but how
that technology is utilized to save
lives at the same time I'm inspired by
the American people who continue social
distancing these cases continue to
decline because of the strong work of
the American people I also wanted to let
you know that we do have nine states
that have less than a thousand cases and
less than 30 new cases per day so we're
looking at States and metro areas as
individual individual areas we talked
before how each of these curves are
different each of the cases experiences
are different we have some states like
California and Washington State Oregon
that never really had a peak because of
so much work that their populations did
to decrease and keep the new cases down
so each of these into individual states
and individual metros are being studied
very specifically I do want to highlight
and we are remaining and we've been
having discussions with Rhode Island
Rhode Island and Providence are in a
unique situation first they had
increasing cases from the New York City
area and now they have new increase in
cases from the Boston area they're
caught between two incredible hotspots
in the country they're doing an
extraordinary job they're caring for the
individuals and the front lines but
Providence continues to have new cases
and we do continue to work with specific
states that have specific outbreaks
related to
individual occurrences I will just
remind the American people again this is
a highly contagious virus social
gatherings coming together is there
always a chance that a a symptomatic
person can spread the virus unknowingly
no one is intending to spread the virus
we know if you are sick you will stay
home but to all of you
that are out there that would like to
join together and just have that dinner
party for twenty don't do it yet
continue to follow the presidential
guidelines we really appreciate the work
of the American people we see as a
country we're improving we see as metro
areas we're improving we see as
communities as counties and as states
were improving but that also still
requires everyone to continue to social
distance and in the end we do have
states that have very few cases and very
few new cases and so these are the ones
a president is referring to on that have
been silent relatively silent throughout
this epidemic and pandemic that many of
us have faced and so these are the
groups are working in with very
specifically and each of these governors
in each of these mayor's will have to
make decisions after generalized
guidelines are put out so that they can
do what's best for their communities
they are at the front line and I wanted
to conclude by really thanking my PEPFAR
teams around the world who have been
working tirelessly throughout the world
to ensure that Africa and Asia doesn't
experience this level of infections that
we have seen here they've turned over
their capacities from their embassies
our US hires throughout the world our
ambassadors are still on the front line
with our local staff working with
ministries of how to confront this virus
around the globe and I assure you that
they are continuing to invest in the
health structures the laboratory and the
frontline care to ensure that all of the
work that we have done against TB HIV
and malaria continues but that we use
our capacity our laboratories our
clinics our hospitals that have been
built by the American people and the
General
ah city of the American people to really
combat this covet 19 around the globe
thank you thank you very much
Thank You mr. president for the
opportunity to be here with you today
and to I want you to know it's an honor
to represent you and leading the
Department of Agriculture and represent
the constituency who are crucial in
maintaining our nation's food security
enabling us to keep food on the table of
our American families not only just food
but wholesome and safe food as well I'd
like to start my remarks today by
echoing what my colleagues the CDC have
been saying regarding the health and
safety of our central employees across
the United States
CDC's provided strategies there that
aimed at helping our most critical
workers both in health care and in food
processing to quickly and safely to
return to work after potential exposure
to covin 19 provided those workers are
symptom free and this guidance will help
these critical industries in the food
sector provide to protect the health and
safety of essential workers while
keeping critical functions working
throughout the Cova 19 response as we
know any employee who develops symptoms
while on the job should go home
immediately and the interim guidance is
in line with CDC's recommendations for
health care workers caring for those
sick with Kovan 19 so we appreciate the
dedication and commitment of all the
brave men and working women working to
keep their communities fed and we will
continue to work with the CDC to keep
those individuals as safe as possible
during these challenging times in that
vein there's been a lot happening this
week it's Cova 19 is impacting food
processing facilities as you know for
Americans who be may be worried about
access to good food because of this I
want to assure you the American food
supply is strong resilient and safe and
in fact our food supply chain has shown
tremendous agility in shifting
production and logistics so suddenly
from restaurant and institutional
settings to retail settings to all the
employers out there in this sector it's
critical that you follow CDC guidelines
and guidance and best practices to keep
all of your employees and people safe
and healthy to employers and local
public health officials advising them
the CDC has issued guidelines on how to
mitigate a situation if you have a
positive case in one of your facilities
we need our local health authorities and
our state health authorities to do
everything they can to balance the
demand of keeping our facilities
operational and our critical industries
going on at the same time keeping the
health and safety of employees is a top
priority as well as our communities so I
want to also take this time to thank all
of our critical essential food supply
chain workers the entire country is
counting on these patriotic individuals
by doing the work in our food supply
chain these dedicated workers include
obviously farmers and producers but also
processors truckers and grocery store
workers as you know America is depending
on what you have the food we need to
feed our families and you're the ones
who are making that happen thank you as
an entire nation we're truly thankful
for the work you're doing and we
recognize that you are the true
patriotic heroes during this national
emergency along with our health care
workers so before I sign off here mr.
president I want to remind you and all
of us of one more thing in the United
States we have plenty of food for all of
our citizens I want to be clear the bear
store shelves you may see in some cities
in the country are a demand issue not a
supply issue the way food is prepared
and packaged to be sold in a restaurant
or a school is significantly different
than the way it's packaged for you to
buy in the grocery store our supply
chain is sophisticated efficient
integrated and synchronized and it's
taken us a few days to relocate the
misalignment between institutional
settings and grocery settings but that
does not mean that we don't have enough
food in this country to feed the
American people you might think of it as
an interstate when it's all flowing
along well and you have a crash at one
place it backs up and that's what's
happening in the food supply chain but
we're working through that you know all
this through all this our food supply
chain is proven to be very resilient
just like American people
extent we have challenges we have and
continue to need to work through it all
together and we can and we will get
through this with a whole of American
approach mr. president and the critical
partnership between state and local
health officials a management of
companies and the employees and we will
meet any challenges we face by working
together thank you sir for the
opportunity before the vice president
comes up I just wanted to say speaking
of sunny China has paid us billions of
dollars many many billions of dollars in
tariffs which we've distributed some to
the farmers because they were targeted
we have many billions of dollars being
held by sunny and I've told him to
distribute much of that money to the
farmers our farmers were targeted and
now they're benefiting by the amount
that they were targeted and we are very
honored to do that and sunny you're
going to start that process very soon
you let the farmers know nobody can take
advantage of our farmers so we have a
lot of money that we've taken in from
China we're going to be distributing
that money from from sunny to the
farmers and is tremendous money over
above that that money was paid directly
into the Treasury of the United States
this has never happened to China before
they never gave us ten cents now they're
paying us billions of dollars that we
appreciate it so thank you very much on
a greatjob breeze Mike please
Thank You mr. president
the White House coronavirus task force
met today was reported to us that we've
conducted and completed three million
three hundred twenty four thousand tests
across the nation more than six hundred
nineteen thousand Americans have tested
positive but as you reflected yesterday
when we welcomed coronavirus survivors
here to the White House from across the
country some more than 45,000 Americans
have fully recovered sadly we mourn the
loss of more than 27 thousand of our our
countrymen our hearts are with their
families and with the families of all of
those that continue to struggle and with
the serious consequences of this illness
but as dr. Burks just reflected despite
the heartbreaking losses we're getting
there America because of the efforts of
people all across this country to put
into practice the president's
coronavirus guidelines because of their
adherence to the direction of state and
local authorities as dr. Burks just
reflected we we see great signs of
progress from the west coast to the East
Coast where President Trump has directed
our team to develop new guidelines that
will be presented tomorrow to our
nation's governors and and released to
the American people thereafter the
American people will be encouraged to
know that as we stand here today 24
percent of the counties of this country
have no reported coronavirus cases in
fact half of the states in America have
less than 2,500 cases per state this is
a great tribute to the efforts by the
people of those communities but as the
president suggested when we unveil the
guidelines that the team has been
working to present tomorrow to our
nation's governors we're going to
reflect on the fact that as the
president said there will be areas of
the country that will require
continued mitigation and strong efforts
and there will be other areas of the
country that will be be given guidance
for greater flexibility the president is
so directed our team when we think of
more than six hundred and nineteen
thousand Americans having tested
positive more than 45,000 having
recovered we wanted to announce today
that the FDA recently announced efforts
to facilitate the development and access
to convalescent plasma mr. president
you've spoken about this people who have
recovered from the corona virus have
antibodies in your bloodstream that can
attack the virus the Mayo Clinic today
is working with the Red Cross to make
sure that coronavirus patients have
access to the convalescent plasma
treatments and over a thousand
institutions across America have already
joined this program and we want to urge
every American who has recovered from
the corona virus for at least two and
preferably four weeks to contact your
local blood or plasma donation center
and arrange to donate it's one more way
that the American people can do their
part and step forward and thousands have
already done so when we know that tens
of thousands will join them on the
subject of supplies mr. president I'll
be very brief because you detailed a
great amount as the president mentioned
the air bridge is completed forty four
flights 56 more are scheduled but on the
subject of facial masks which are so
important for the protection of critical
infrastructure pleased to report that
the average daily delivery through the
commercial network through our air
bridge is 22 million facial masks coming
into the marketplace the average
inventory in the network over a seven
day period is 80 million masks and FEMA
is actually working as we speak to move
facial masks to priority infrastructure
food supply first responders there'll be
six point five million masks that go out
before the end of this week an
additional 20 million before April the
20th and then we'll be adding six point
five million each and every
at the president's direction we're going
to ensure that all of those that work in
food supply all of those first
responders have access to masks and
we're increasing those every day now
finally I know I speak for the president
when I say how proud we are of all of
our health care workers across the
country and how proud we are of the men
and women in uniform our medical
professionals who have been deployed
across the nation literally by the
thousands in fact as we stand here today
576 doctors nurses and other military
medical professionals have been deployed
to 13 hospitals across the nation 10 in
New York and one in Connecticut Texas in
Louisiana each and as the president
reflected a few days ago because we did
not have the happily did not have the
demand on the Javits Center and on the
Comfort in New York City at the
president's direction we have deployed
doctors and nurses from those two
facilities two hospitals in fact the
president and I were just speaking to
mayor de Blasio just before we came out
and he expressed his great admiration
and appreciation for the relief that
these medical military personnel have
provided two incredibly dedicated people
in our hospitals 258 medical personnel
just yesterday were deployed off the
ship and out of the Javits Center into
New York with that mr. president I'll
step aside but it's remarkable to think
of all that we've accomplished over the
last month since you first issued the
presidential guidelines for America the
truth is because of what the American
people have done over the last 30 days
we are slowing the spread we are
ensuring that every American family to
have access to the health care that we
want any member of our family to have
with the greatest health care
professionals in the world we're saving
lives and we're healing our land and so
we want to thank the American people for
all you have done and tomorrow we'll be
presenting a new guidance to the
governors of this country about how we
build on our progress and reopen America
in a safe and responsible way Thank You
mr. president
thank you
on the recess appointment mr. president
I could very simple if they don't act on
getting these people approved that we
need because of the we need them anyway
but we especially need now because of
the pandemic we are going to do
something that will be something I'd
prefer not doing but which I should do
and I will do if I have to Caitlin go
ahead that's what I want to do we have
great tests and we want the states to
administer these tests for the most part
but we're standing behind them we have
great tests we've done more testing now
than any country as you know in the
world by far we have the best tests of
any country in the world nobody has the
quality of tests the if you look at
Abbott what they've come up with in a
short period of time they've been
incredible Roche has been incredible we
have the best tests in the world and we
will be working very much with the
governors of the states we want them to
do it we're not going to be running a
parking lot in Arkansas we're not going
to be running a parking lot where you
have a Walmart which has been great by
the way Walmart has done a fantastic job
but where you have a testing center and
running that from Washington DC the
states are much better equipped to do it
but we'll be working with the states
we're standing behind the states we're
going to work very closely with the
governor's in terms of that getting
additional equipment it used to be three
four weeks ago two weeks ago could we
get more ventilators more ventilators
right and we got on ventilators and you
don't hear that anymore it's pretty
amazing what we've been able to do yeah
go ahead John
widespread enough to wear these
well I think the companies will
determine that and the governor's will
determine that and the federal
government and if we're not happy we'll
take very strong action against a state
or a governor if we're not happy with
the job of governor's doing we'll let
them know about it and as you know we
have very strong action we can take
including a closed-down but we don't
want to do that we're working with the
governor's that we're working closely
with the governor's the relationship has
been very good vice president has had a
lot of conversations over the last two
weeks with either 50 or almost 50
governor's on every conversation and
they've been really positive
conversations we have the right to do
whatever we want but we wouldn't do that
but no we would have the right to close
down what they're doing if we want to do
that but we don't want to do that and I
don't think there'll be any reason to do
that but we have the right to do that
Steve well I don't know too much about
it but I understand my name is there I
don't know where they're going how
they're going I do understand it's not
delaying anything and I'm satisfied with
that I don't I don't imagine it's a big
deal I'm sure people will be very happy
to get a big fat beautiful check and my
name is on it
yeah go ahead please
from people that are coming from Boston
in New York you just said you'd like to
reopen some states before May 1 how will
you stop at second spiking pages with
people with travelling between states
how we control the flow of people well
the governor's can control that flow as
an example in fact I just saw a little
while ago it was reported that certain
borders are being controlled already by
States they're starting to take control
of their borders which is good so
they'll be controlling they may do
testing for people wanting to come in
I'd read that about Rhode Island so they
have to watch it they have to be very
careful yeah please you said along with
other nations what form would it take
are you considering also relaxing the
border between Canada and the US so our
relationship with Canada is very good
we'll talk about that it will be one of
the early borders to be released
Canada's doing well we're doing well
we'll see but at some point we'll be
doing that in the meantime nations that
are heavily infected we have a lot of
nations that are heavily infected some
are getting better some are still in the
way up unfortunately and we're keeping
very strong borders with those nations
but with Canada we are talking about
different things yeah please the
president you said the evidence suggests
that nationwide we have passed the peak
on new cases what's your evidence for
that what are the numbers well all we're
doing is looking at the numbers we're
looking at our graphs we're looking at
our models we're getting a great
response from Debra and from Tony and
from many of the professionals that are
working we have great professionals
working with us and I think based on
that we're we're doing very well based
on that it looks like we're headed
absolutely in the right direction but
some states are looking at other states
and they're saying I can't imagine what
they're going through because they're
not in that position they're in very
good shape I would say that we have 20
states at least but you really have 29
that are an extremely good shape you
have others that are getting much better
and I think with almost few exceptions
you have every state that is either
doing better or on the way to doing
better yeah please yeah go ahead
threat to a adjourn or adjourn Congress
clearly of the power article two section
three but that'd be quite radical to do
earlier or last month you were in the
office talked about now is not the time
for partisanship how will that act lower
the partisanship in this town and could
it potentially hinder your ability to
get something done on coronavirus it is
look it's been a very partisan
government for a long period of time not
just this administration you can go back
into the last two administrations you've
seen a lot of partisanship and even now
you would think that we wouldn't have as
an example with the paycheck plan that's
going so well it's so smooth so
beautiful almost without a hitch all of
that money is being distributed to small
businesses they're giving it to their
employees it's keeping them ready viable
so when we open and now it's been so
good that it's almost depleted and we
want to replenish it and we can't get
the Democrats to approve it and that's a
program that they and everybody else
admit that are great so you do have
partisanship we have been trying for
years to get people approved for
positions people have left one man left
a law firm one man left a big change it
was a very successful executive he left
it was two years ago we have people that
have been waiting for three years and we
can't get them approved by the Democrats
in the Senate because they're taking so
long to approve our judges now I have to
tell you that I'm totally in favor of
what mitch is doing with judges because
that's always seems to be a priority and
it's a very important priority I think
it's one of the great trademarks of this
administration we've approved record
numbers of federal judges and appellate
judges and two Supreme Court judges but
rather than approving somebody who's
highly qualified somebody that everybody
knows is going to be approved rather
than going quickly they take the maximum
amount of time whatever that time may be
and what they're doing by doing that is
taking days to approve somebody that
could be approved in a quick vote people
that get phenomenal reviews in committee
are going maximum number of hours and
what they do is there's only so many
hours of the day now we could have said
let's stay I would have been in favor of
that they didn't choose to do it but I
have a very strong power I'd rather not
use that power but we have way over a
hundred people that we very badly need
in this administration that should have
been approved a long time ago and one of
them is the head of Voice of America if
you look at what they're doing and what
they're saying about our country it's a
disgrace the people that are running
that we have somebody that's really good
really talented and that loves our
country and I want to get these people
approved that's one of many we have
professionals Sonny you've been waiting
for how long have you been waiting for
the man that we're talking about coming
in two and a half years so sonny perdue
just happens to be here talking about
something else so you've been waiting
for one of the most important positions
as Secretary of Agriculture is the
position its distribution we need it now
we're talking about shelves we're
talking about cupboards he needs it he's
been waiting he didn't know he's going
to get this question you've been waiting
2 and 1/2 years the person is
exceptional that person left a very good
job and it's embarrassing to me he'll
say do you think you'll get that man
approved he's been saying that to me for
a long time it's because of the
Democrats and what we're doing is and I
think anybody here would do it judges
are a priority a federal judge is going
to sit for 50 years potentially young
judge got to be sitting for that's
always going to have to be a priority
but because they're taking so much time
and approving everywhere they're trying
to put us through the mill that's when
you talk about partisanship and it's
never ever happened before you can look
at every administration of the history
of this country nobody nobody has ever
had hundreds of people not approved
after three and a half years go ahead
place timeline for that though if if
Congress doesn't know they've been
warned and they've been warned right now
if they don't approve it that we're
gonna go this route and we'll probably
be challenged in court
and we'll see who wins but when the
court hears that we aren't getting
people approved as Sonny would say for
two and a half years for an important
position that we need because of this
crisis we needed these people before but
now we really need these people back to
the numbers for a second when you talk
about the numbers the jobless claims are
gonna come out tomorrow it's likely
around 5 million more Americans putting
their names in front employment benefits
but yet there are still a couple
thousand people as well dying a day
because of coronavirus when you talk
about opening up the American economy or
at least in parts now how do you balance
that decision out given both of those
figures well we are there has to be a
balance you know there's also death
involved in keeping it close and I've
gone over this with you and I believe
this so strongly when you look at mental
health when you look at suicides suicide
hotlines who which are exploding people
losing their jobs when you look at drugs
and people that didn't take drugs and
now they're becoming drug addicted
because they're going through a problem
they have no job they have no money
coming in other than the money we're
getting them we've opened up the coffers
to a large extent we're helping people
this is why I wish the Democrats would
help us a little bit with it because
they should it's purely partisan what
they're doing and it's bad for our
country but but you know there is death
by doing by having this strongly closed
country we have to get back to work with
all of that being said we're going to
start with States and with governors
that have done a great job and they're
going to open it up as they see fit and
we're going to be right behind them and
we're going to be working we're going to
be supplying them with things if they
don't have them we want them to have
them we're going to be helping them with
ventilators after this is over so that
they can't say oh the federal government
we want them to have they've had a lot
of options many of the governors have
had a lot of options over the years to
buy ventilators they didn't choose to do
it so we're going to be helping them to
fill up their stockpiles we're going to
have plenty and as I said I'm very proud
to do it we're going to be helping other
nations we're going to be helping Italy
Spain France other nations and we're
going to be helping them strongly I
think
Russia is going to need ventilators
having a hard time in Moscow we're gonna
help them we're gonna help other
countries that need ventilators we're
gonna have a lot you see it with General
Motors you see it with other companies
that are producing we're going to have
hundreds of thousands of ventilators and
it's a great thing to have yes in the
back place is anybody freezing you know
it's very cold out here so we can leave
early
well you don't know what you have do you
think you're getting honest numbers from
some of these countries do you really
believe those numbers in this vast
country called China and that they have
a certain number of cases and a certain
number of that does anybody really
believe that here's the story
we report everything we're reporting the
cases and our reporting is good we're
reporting every death in fact I see this
morning where New York added 3,000
deaths because they died and they're now
saying rather than it was a heart attack
they're saying it was a heart attack
caused by this so they're adding if you
look at it that's it and everything we
have is documented reported and what
they are doing is just in case they're
calling it this and that's okay that's
okay but we are we have more cases
because we do more reporting we have
more cases because everything is down
but does anybody really believe the
numbers of some of these countries that
you've been watching and you've been
reporting on and then it's like they
didn't have the big thing there have
been some really really bad heavily and
really some countries that are in big
big trouble and they're not reporting
the facts and that's up to them all I
know is we report the facts and we're a
country that's getting better John go
ahead mr. president multiple sources are
telling Fox News today that the United
States government now has high
confidence that while the coronavirus is
a naturally occurring virus it emanated
from a virology lab in Wuhan that
because of lack safety protocols and in
turn was infected
who later infected her boyfriend and
then went to the wet market in Wuhan
where it began to spread does that
correspond with what you have heard from
well I don't want to say that John but I
will tell you more and more we're
hearing the story and we'll see when you
say multiple sources though there's a
case where you can use the word sources
but we are doing a very thorough
examination of this horrible situation
that happened go ahead please in your
many conversations with President Xi mr.
president did you ever discuss with him
State Department concerns about lack
safety protocols that had been recorded
to the State Department from the embassy
in Beijing about that laboratory I don't
want to discuss what I talked to him
about the laboratory I just don't want
to discuss it it's inappropriate right
now please go ahead in the back to make
funding for w-h-o conditional on reforms
to the organization I wanted to get your
thoughts on that and if you had any
advice for mr. Morrison look I feel very
badly about the World Health
Organization but it's been a tool of
China it's been as I say totally China
centric you take a look at everything
that's happened they've been wrong I was
all for it at the beginning what do I
know I worked in I said World Health
Organization isn't that wonderful and
then you start to see all the mistakes
they didn't want us to close our borders
to China to Wuhan specifically they
didn't want our borders closed you take
a look Mike was there we're all there
and they're criticizing me for closing
the border I did that very early by the
way I did that very early well Nancy
Pelosi was trying to have in San
Francisco parties in Chinatown because
they she thought it would be great you
want to show that this thing doesn't
exist
these are people I say we have some
politicians on the other side that don't
know what they're doing if you look at
if you look at timelines you got to look
at some timelines but the world the
world health organization just like the
World Trade Organization I'm telling you
I call them they have been treating the
United States for decades so badly and
they've been so in favor of China China
took off when it joined the World Trade
Organization because of what's happened
think of it they're considered a
nation and because there and we're not
but we're developing nation to in my
book okay we're developing to but the
fact is we have been treated so badly by
these organizations and believe me I'm
looking at that one too we're winning a
lot of lawsuits right now that we never
won before in the past we're winning a
lot of money that we never won in the
past that's what the world trade but
with the World Health Organization
what's happened there is a disgrace
here's the other thing we pay 400 to 500
million dollars a year China's paying 38
39 and 40 million dollars a year and
it's like they control this group I
could do that too if I wanted to vote
full-time to it or have some very
capable people dealing with doctor
Tetris okay I could do it too I could do
very well with that
but there's something going on is
something going on that's very bad now
the 500 million that we save will
determine we're going to make a
determination over a little period of
time but they're going to either have to
make massive changes I don't even know
if they're going to be able to do that
or we're gonna give money to people we
want to help people you know what we do
in Africa with AIDS people have no idea
what we do and the money we spent we
were talking about it the other day
doctor we are spending billions of
dollars to help people in the case of
one that dr. Burks is very much involved
in AIDS millions of dollars and you know
what it's a great thing nobody talks
about it nobody gives us credit we do
that and we do it very directly but
we're spending billions of dollars to
help people live and all over the world
but we're spending five hundred million
dollars to the World Health Organization
and there's something very bad going on
and you know what I've gotten very much
involved it's been going on for a long
period of time and we don't want to be
the suckers anymore so it's cold out we
will talk to you tomorrow big day
tomorrow
very big